six months after npr published a review
of hunter biden's memoir
beautiful things they're issuing a
bombshell correction to the story
after falsely claiming that the story
about hunter's laptop
was quote discredited by intelligence
agents
the review initially read the laptop
story was discredited by us
intelligence and independent
investigations by news organizations
now the stunning mia culpa reads
numerous news organizations cast doubt
on the credibility of the laptop story
no mention of intelligence nor
independent investigations just
news organizations so let's bring in our
panel charlie kirk founder of turning
point usa
and alicia kraus host of the washington
examiner newsmaker series
alicia i'm going to start with you um
why after five months
are they coming out with this and you
know this would have really could have
made a big
difference in the election back in
october
not only could this exchange have made a
big change have made a difference
another change that could have made a
difference was the washington post
remember after the election when they
were talking about
um the the transcript from georgia and
their source
actually completely made stuff up i mean
i'm not completely surprised that the
american people are continually
distrustful
of not just our institutions like what
the cdc has been doing
but of our media as a whole why should
they trust when these are pretty
big details that the major news media is
completely ignoring
right